Prof: All right?
All right.
Let us begin.
Let us--we'll turn down the
music of Charles Ives.
We'll come back to the music of
Charles Ives,
but let us begin with our
discussion of musical
form--continuing our discussion
of musical form.
Last time we talked really
about three forms.
We talked about verse and
chorus in popular music and we
had a wonderful presentation by
Frederick Evans.
And I hope you came away with
the following:
that in dealing with verse and
chorus, basically,
you have the same material;
you have the same musical
material coming back again and
again and again.
With the chorus we actually
have the same text coming back
again and again and again.
But with the verses although
the music is the same,
the text keeps changing each
time.
We get new strophes--or new
verses--of text.
So keep that in mind:
verse, chorus,
verse, chorus.
Sometimes this can start with
the chorus.
Sometimes there's a harmonic
change in here that we would
call the bridge,
but essentially it's the
repetition of the same material
over and over again in terms of
the music--
but in terms of the text,
you get new text each time for
the verses.
We also talked about the
simplest of all of these musical
forms: ternary form.
Right?
And that was simply this idea
of statement,
contrast, statement--A,
B, A.
Very straightforward,
not too much we need do with
that.
Today we're going to go on and
talk about theme and variations,
and with regard to all three of
these I should say that all
three of these forms are very
old.
I could go back into the Middle
Ages and get a responsory of the
Middle Ages that is in A B A
form.
I could go back into the Middle
Ages and bring up an early
fifteenth-century English carol
that's in verse and chorus form.
I could go back into the Middle
Ages and find you instrumental
pieces that are in theme and
variation form.
So these three are very old.
Now, the fourth one that we
talked about,
sonata-allegro form,
is adventitious.
It's something constructed in
the eighteenth century--
adventitious to the eighteenth
century--
so it's something put together
in some measure by Joseph Haydn
and then passed on to his good
friend,
Wolfgang Amadeus Mozart.
So sonata-allegro form--this
big, complex musical form--is a
little bit different than the
other.
It's a lot younger.
It's a lot newer--beginning
with the period of classical
music--Mozart,
Haydn, and Beethoven.
All right.
With that by way of an
introduction,
let's go back to sonata-allegro
form.
We said that was the largest,
the most complex,
of these musical forms.
Why are we dealing with this?
Well, next--a week from
Saturday--we will go to this
concert and we will sit there
and we listen to pieces on this
concert.
The opening piece will be in
sonata-allegro form.
It will be by Mozart.
Then we will have a piece by
Johannes Brahms in theme and
variation form.
Then we will have a symphony by
Beethoven in five
movements--it's an exception and
we'll explain why when we get to
it--in five movements.
But within those movements we
have a couple of instances of
sonata-allegro form,
a couple of instances of theme
and variation form,
and one instance of ternary
form.
So all of these forms will be
necessary.
We will have to understand how
these forms work in order for us
to really engage that particular
concert.
For example,
you'll be asked to write a
review of that concert.
And I was thinking this
morning, well,
a kind of mediocre review would
say,
"Well, in the middle of
the first movement of the
Beethoven piece--
and we--once again,
we wouldn't call it a 'song'--
in the middle of the
Beethoven--first movement of the
Beethoven symphony--
things seem to be
disorganized."
What I'd like to hear there is
"Well,
in the development section--in
the development section--
of the first movement of the
Beethoven symphony,
it seemed disorganized because
the counterpoint was not clear,
because the imitative entries
of the parts was not clearly
articulated."
And that would be a much more
specific sort of response to the
music, a much more educated,
if you will,
response to the music.
So that's where we're going
with all this to get you to
think about precisely where you
are and precisely what should be
happening,
and then, is it really
happening the way it should be.
Now as said,
sonata-allegro form is the most
difficult of these,
and it takes a little extra
time to get familiar with it.
We're going to be reviewing
this in section starting this
evening.
And don't forget we have this
model of what sonata-allegro
form is.
I didn't want to put that up on
the board again--did that last
time--but you've got it on page
one hundred ninety-three of your
textbook.
If you want that complex
diagram, one hundred
ninety-three of your textbook.
So get familiar with that.
And do, once again,
bring your books to section
this time, 'cause we'll read
them in section this time.
So we've got this complex form.
nd I've figured out over the
years the way to sort of wrap
your arms around this or get
into this, understand this.
And it involves the fact that
music in the classical period is
what we would call rhetorical
music.
It's doing something at every
moment.
It is doing,
as I see it,
one of four things.
It's presenting a theme so
we'll have a--what we call a
thematic function.
It's moving from point A to
point B.
Remember with the Beethoven
>
--that's the opening theme,
and then the second theme is
>.
Well, those are both themes.
That's stating something that
we can sing, that we can
remember.
But Beethoven has to get from
point A, the minor,
to point B, the more lyrical
major, so he writes a
transition.
So the second functional type
here is transitional music.
We want to be able to
differentiate thematic music
from transitional music.
Then there are passages--and in
sonata-allegro form it's in the
middle of the movement--
that are exclusively
developmental,
where you take the material and
play with it.
You could make it--expand it
and change it that way.
You could shorten it as
Beethoven often does in working
with just particular motives.
It tends to sound very complex.
There's a lot going on in the
development section.
It's the most polyphonic,
the most contrapuntal--
counterpoint and
polyphony--sort of synonymous--
the most complex in terms of
the counterpoint and,
as we said before,
it tends to move around a lot
because they pass--
the composers will pass through
different keys in the
development section.
So we've got,
so far, three of what we call
the four functional types--
or what I have called the four
functional types:
thematic,
transitional, developmental.
And now we have to talk about
the last one,
which is the simplest in some
ways: cadential--
where the composer will just
throw on a lot of heavy,
simple harmonic motion to slow
the music down psychologically--
not the tempo actually--but
psychologically sort of bring it
to a close,
so we can say a closing
functional type.
Again to review:
thematic, transitional,
developmental and cadential.
Those are our four functional
types that will show up with any
movement of sonata-allegro form.
Question.
Student: What was the
last one?
Prof: Cadential,
with--was that it,
Dan?
It's Daniel.
Is that right?
Student: Yes.
Prof: Yeah.
Student: How do you
spell that?
Prof: Well,
just take cadence,
c-a-d-e-n-c-e,
and turn it into cadential,
t-i-a-l.
I don't know if my spellchecker
kicks that word back or not,
but we use that term in music a
lot.
"This was a cadential
gesture,"
suggesting that we're kind of
getting to the end of something.
So, remember we had cadence
being the end of a phrase.
Well, it's just the end of the
section here.
Any other questions?
That was a good question.
All right.
So to get rolling with this,
let's listen to some music now.
Enough talk from me.
Let's get--listen to some
music, and I'm going to play
four excerpts here--
mostly here again from
Mozart--four excerpts--
and you see if you can identify
which of the functional types is
in play here <<music
playing>>
Okay. We're going to stop there.
Let's review just for a moment.
How do you tell these
functional types?
Well, what are you looking for
here, or listening for?
With thematic,
you want to be able to kind of
sing it or you recognize it as
something that you could walk
out of here humming.
So something that's--that you
can sort of take with you.
Transitional:
this idea of a little bit
unsettled and lots of motion.
Cadential--as I say,
that's probably the easiest
because >
, something like that,
bringing it to an end.
And developmental is going to
be rather complex--lots of
counterpoint going on.
So let's go back to the
beginning.
>
Okay. So that's number one.
Here's extract number two
>
and excerpt number three
and number four.
>
All right. Let's go back now.
Let's hear "one"
one more time and then we're
going to ask for a volunteer to
take a stab at which of the four
functional types you think this
is.
Okay.
Number one, one more time.
>
So what brave soul will take
this one on?
Sorry. Carolyn, please.
Transitional.
That is correct.
Yes, that's correct.
Now what did you hear there?
It's hard to play the whole
thing again, but what were you
thinking?
What came--what--why did you
jump to that conclusion?
Student:
>
Prof: Okay.
At the end of it,
it did kind of slow down.
You had a sense of arrival
there.
There was lots of motion.
There was lots of movement,
and then at the end a sense of
arrival.
All right.
We've arrived at a new--and
probably a theme is going to
come in at that point.
So that is, in fact,
a transition.
>
What about that one?
Frederick, go ahead.
You had your hand up first.
Student: That was the
cadential version because it
seemed--
a lot of monotony,
kind of, in the bass,
and it's really leaning to the
descending,
more the sequence of the melody
and it's coming to a close in
>.
Prof: Okay.
Well, I think the key there is
it's very monotonous.
You used the word
"monotonous."
It's very monotonous in the
bass, >
or something like that as the
melody cascades down against it,
but listening to the bass there
you can tell the--
that's just a very monotonous
harmonic pattern.
So harmonic patterns in
cadential passages
here--cadential functional
type--tend to be,
as Frederick says,
monotonous.
Okay.
Let's go on to number three
now.
>
Let's just stop it right there
and queue that one again.
So what do you think about
that?
Name, please?
Student: Roger.
Prof: Roger.
Okay.
Fire away, Roger.
Student: I think that's
thematic.
Prof: Thematic, right.
Can you sing it?
Play it again for Roger.
We're really putting Roger on
the spot here this morning but
let's see.
You don't have to be--
>
And I'll play at the piano.
Okay.
So that's it?
Roger says I just played it
so--all right.
So that is a melody.
And let's queue that again and
just while we're at this,
notice what Mozart does with
this melody after giving it to
us--
sort of does some very
interesting I think.
So let's have the beginning of
that same number three again,
please.
>
So here's our lovely
melody--major or minor?
Major: sweet, sounds delightful.
Now watch what he does here,
just drops a third,
>
just a little twist in minor
there--same melody,
but just lowering that third
degree of the scale.
Okay.
So that's a good example of
thematic functional type.
Here is extract number four.
What about this one?
>
Okay, and we'll just stop it
there and you can go on to the
next one.
Well, what about that one?
Yeah, go for the obvious answer
here.
It's going to be--name, please?
Lana. Well, I beg your pardon?
Student: Developmental.
Prof: Developmental,
and why?
What did you--well,
yeah, because it's the only one
left,
etc., etc., but did you--could
you tell us something that you
heard there that sort of backs
that up or confirms that it is
developmental?
Student: It has many
threads weaving in and out.
Prof: Yeah,
many threads weaving in and
out, >
, and somebody else is doing
>
, all sort of
simultaneously--many different
ideas happening simultaneously,
typical of the complexity of
the development section.
We've got some on the tape here.
We're not going to go through
them quite so slowly.
Let's play one more.
It could be any one of the four.
Here's another one, number five.
>
Okay.
Takers there?
Name, please.
I should know it--the young
lady right in front of Thaddeus.
You had your hand up first.
Student: Oh--Mary Pat.
Prof: Mary Pat, okay.
Student: Was that
transitional?
Prof: It was
transitional and in just the one
hearing that's awfully good,
but you could hear it kind of
build >
and then it stopped as if it
had arrived at the end of the
transition;
the musical journey was over.
So that was transitional.
Here's another one.
>
Takers there?
Thaddeus.
Student: Developmental.
Prof: Okay.
It was developmental.
Excellent.
And I guess once again lots of
things going on there.
Probably developmental and
transitional may sound most
similar.
They're probably the two that
are most difficult to
differentiate.
Thematic, yeah,
you can kind of remember that
as a melody;
cadential, probably pretty
straightforward.
So there's a tendency with--to
confuse the transitional and the
developmental.
It's just that there's
oftentimes with developmental a
lot more counterpoint going on.
All right.
One last one here and then
we'll stop this.
>
So he's driving that sucker
into the ground with sort of a
sledgehammer of a cadential
ending there.
Okay?
So that should help you.
When we get to sections this
week, we're going to be playing
pieces and have you track along
where we are in sonata-allegro
form.
Let's turn our attention now,
unless there are questions.
Any questions about that?
If not, let's turn our
attention now to theme and
variation.
We're moving on to theme and
variation form,
which we will also need for our
concert a week from Saturday.
Here what we have is not this
sort of complex organic mixture
of many different themes--
first theme,
second theme,
concluding theme and things
like that.
We have one theme,
usually-- usually just one
theme.
And we will get that theme.
And then we will get that theme
again with something changed.
Then we will get that material
And again with something
changed.
So think of this as a kind of
series of boxcars on a railroad
train or something like that--
units more or less the same
size, but each of those boxcars
is going to look a little bit
different as it goes by because
it might have a little different
logo on it or a little bit of
different ornamental material on
it.
All right.
So we're going to--let's see.
For time, maybe I'll--we'll not
do the Ives.
We were going to--well,
maybe we will have a little bit
of Ives.
Theme and variations:
again, it goes all the way back
to the Middle Ages and it--
they tend to be written on
rather simple themes,
particularly patriotic themes,
maybe--
I was thinking about this the
other day--
maybe because patriotic themes
are pretty simple.
So the simpler the theme,
the more likely that theme is
to become the basis of a set of
theme and variations.
Maybe it gives the composer
more freedom to pursue .
Now I think I brought in some
variations of Beethoven on
"God Save the King."
Yeah, here we go.
So here's Beethoven writing
"God Save the King"
and here it starts out.
>.
All right.
So, a very simple tune.
And then he writes a set of
variations.
Here's variation one.
>
So there is that tune.
Now in the late nineteen
thirty--twentieth
century--Yale's own Charles
Ives--I think he was class
of--anybody know?
Oh, 1898, something like that.
He used to be the organist in
the First Church on the Green
here,
so this is Yale's most famous
classical composer--
wrote a set of variations on
this same tune,
but they sound a little bit
different because it's closer to
the modern period and they're
performed here on an organ.
So Charles Ives,
"Variations on
America."
>
Boy, talk about a long
reverberation time,
how long it took that organ
sound to clear that church,
huh?
So that was written right here
in New Haven by our own Charles
Ives.
But again the point is that
it's a very simple idea;
it's a rather simple tune.
Here's another simple tune that
Mozart used.
Its original title was
"Variations on Ah!
Vous Dirai-Je,
Maman,"
"Ah, let me tell you,
Mama."
And it's the--it's a story of a
young woman who has gone to the
big city and,
unfortunately,
lost her virginity.
But we know this tune
not with that French text that
Mozart first learned it with,
but this way.
>
Okay.
So that's the tune but it
originally was a kind of French
popular song going back in--to
at least the eighteenth century.
How many different titles can
we give to this?
What do you know this as?
Student: "Twinkle,
Twinkle, Little Star."
Prof: "Twinkle,
Anything else?
What?
Student: "Baa,
Baa, Black Sheep."
Prof: "Baa,
Didn't "Sesame
Street" used to do- use
letters with it,
"A, B, C,
D," >
and so on.
So it's gotten a lot of its
traction over the years.
And here is the melody
>
and here is the first variation.
Now my question to you is this:
with theme and variation,
the composer can keep the theme
more or less exactly as it is
and change the context around
it,
or he can change the theme--so
which does Mozart do in the
first variation here?
>
Thoughts about that?
Is he changing the theme or is
he keeping the theme exactly the
same and changing stuff around
it?
What do you think?
Well, what he's doing is
changing the theme.
The theme would go
>
but right at the beginning
instead of, I get <<plays
piano>>
so there's only really one note
that's--that relates to the
theme there and then
>
well, now I get-- <<plays
piano>>
So he's sort of changing the
theme by making the notes go
quicker, and ornamenting around
those notes so that's variation
one.
Now what about variation two?
Has he changed the theme or
does he just change all the
stuff around the theme?
>
And so on.
So what's he doing there?
Carolyn.
Student:
>
Prof: Changing what?
I'm sorry.
I couldn't hear you.
Student:
>
Prof: Changing the
context.
The theme in the right hand
stays exactly <<plays
piano>>
the same.
Okay. Here is the next one.
>
What's that?
Well, it goes with this.
>
So has he changed the theme?
Yeah, he's changed the theme
rather considerably there.
Indeed, <<plays
piano>>
we wouldn't know that that had
anything to do with
"Twinkle,
Twinkle, Little Star"
unless we had had--
given to us previously,
as we have--
the melody.
>
So we are hearing in our inner
ear.
>
So we know that's the basis of
this.
And if he wants to deviate from
that we can still say,
"Oh, yeah,
that's related to that."
That's getting rather far away
from the original because we
sort of locked in the original
in our mind--in our ear at that
point.
Here is--oh,
let's--yeah,
let's skip that one.
We don't need to hear it.
What happens here?
Is the theme changed or is it
still there, and the context
changed.
And what rhythmic device is
Mozart using here?
>
So did he change the theme
there?
Well, basically no,
except just a little bit
because he was doing what to it?
>
Using syncopation--so he was
syncopating the theme.
>
That kind of thing.
And he did one other little
fill-up here,
if you will,
in what we might call the B
section of the tune.
>
The tune originally went
and now it's going
>
and then <<plays
piano>>.
So what's he done to the melody?
Anybody hear that?
He went <<plays
piano>>.
Now it's going <<plays
Oscar.
Student:
>
Prof: Yeah.
He has filled in the notes of a
diatonic major scale
>
with <<plays
piano>>
the other notes--the
black-keyed notes--here,
making it a chromatic scale.
So he's enriched it a little
bit by means of chromaticism.
All right.
Let's go on to another
variation by Mozart here.
What's the texture of this
variation?
>
What do you think about the
texture of that?
Homophonic, monophonic,
or polyphonic?
Polyphonic, yeah.
Was it imitative or
non-imitative?
Here's the beginning.
>
Imitative, right,
so this is actually a kind of
throwback to the sound of Bach.
And this is what we will be
engaging when we come to the
fugue.
It's las if Mozart's trying to
write in a fugal way here,
with lots of imitation.
And what happened to the mode
in this variation?
>
Well, he's running it up as a
scale--but what kind of scale?
Minor scale.
>
Okay.
And then, oddly,
the final variation.
What does he do to the meter in
this last variation?
>
What happens there?
We were going--
>
So what's he done to the meter?
Well, let me strip away the
bass-- <<plays
piano>>
He's changed it to triple by
throwing in an extra bar of
filler in between each of his
basic duple beats.
Then we come to,
maybe-- let me just cut to the
chase here.
At the end of this,
he's coming in-- <<plays
piano>>
What's this all the way to the
end now?
What do we call this formally?
>
We talked about that with
regard to sonata-allegro form.
It was one of the parts that
shows up also in sonata-allegro
form--has nothing to do,
really, with the theme here.
It is a good example of a coda,
right, just something thrown on
at the end to say this is at the
end >
--and what's he doing here?
What is this?
How complex is this?
>
It's just a major triad.
He's just ornamenting a major
triad so it's a good--more
cadential stuff--sort of very
simple material at the end.
Okay. Our guest artist is here.
I see him at the back.
Kensho, come on up.
We're going to do another piece
for you and we're going to talk
about--a little bit about
Kensho, a very interesting guy.
How many of you know Kensho
Watanabe?
Have you seen Kensho around?
Okay.
Who has seen Kensho and in what
context?
Student: He's in my
biochemistry class.
Prof: Oh,
"he's in my biochemistry
class." All right.
Yeah, cool.
So that means he does hardcore
sciences and you must too.
Good for you.
You're better--a far better man
than I.
All right.
So yeah, hardcore sciences.
Anybody else know Kensho from
other contexts?
Yeah, Alana.
Student: He's in the YSO.
Prof: He's in the YSO.
What does he do in the YSO?
Do you see him sitting all the
way at the back?
Student:
>
Prof: No.
You see him sitting all the way
up at the front.
He's the concert master of the
YSO.
Anybody else know Kensho in a
different context?
Any members of Berkeley College
here?
Anybody from Berkeley?
Nobody from Berkeley?
That's a statistical
improbability,
but you're the conductor of
the--one of the conductors of
the Berkeley Chamber Orchestra.
Right?
Yeah.
So he's a conductor too,
which is kind of astonishing
because he's not--really not a
very good musician.
He doesn't really know very
much about music.
>
Kensho, what note is that?
Kensho: I don't know--A?
Prof: Yeah.
What note is this?
>
Kensho: F-sharp.
Prof: What note is this?
>
Kensho: E and A.
Prof: Yeah. E and an A.
You know that so he has a very
keen sense of absolute pitch,
which really helps you out if
you're in music,
needless to say.
We will be- we'll be talking
more about this.
One person in ten thousand has
this particular gift,
statistically,
so he's a very impressive guy.
And he's also in the five-year
M.A./B.A.
program.
Right?
Kensho: Yeah, the B.A.
Prof: Yeah,
so at the end of four years
here in addition to taking all
these heavy-duty science classes
he's been--
crossed the street and he's
going to get an M.A.
in music at the same time.
I don't know.
He was a couple minutes late
today and he said he hadn't got
much sleep and I can sure as
heck understand why.
All right.
So we have the--Kensho,
what are up to this year?
Everybody can come see you
on--what would that be?
The 31^(st) of October ? Go--
Kensho:
>
Prof: Yeah,
yeah, so that you don't want to
miss.
Right?
Kensho: Yeah.
Prof: And you kind of
have to put that together and
maybe that's why you haven't
been getting much sleep.
So you're putting that together
and tell--
and I know that you've got a
concert coming up and if for
some reason--
God forbid--we can't make it to
our concert on the eighteenth,
our make-up concert could very
well be the one on the
nineteenth.
Don't you have a concert on
the^( )nineteenth?
Kensho: Yes,
we do.
The Berkeley College Orchestra
will have their first concert.
Prof: So if you want to
hear Kensho conduct,
you could do that on the
nineteenth of October.
All right.
So we've got a piece here--and
I don't want to get too far
behind.
It's a piece by Corelli.
It's based on a melody and a
bass pattern--
melody and a bass pattern--and
we'll play through little bits
of it here,
and then we're going to play
the whole thing.
Do we need to tune again?
What do you think?
Kensho: Yeah.
Prof: Yeah. Okay.
>
Okay.
We've tuned the four strings of
the violin and we'll play just a
little bit.
We're going to take this
section by section.
Jacob here, he's going to point
things out as we go along a
little bit.
>
Okay. That's the melody.
Isn't that the most gorgeous
sound you've ever heard in your
whole--
it's amazing,
but do you have any idea how
long it takes to produce a sound
like that,
how many years of just sitting
there?
When did you start playing the
violin, Kensho?
Kensho: I started when I
was almost three--
Prof: Almost three--so
you were a late bloomer,
then.
>
And you were probably so busy
with other things--but when you
were really focusing exclusively
on this, how many hours a day
did you practice?
Kensho: When I was
really focusing,
probably three hours a day.
Prof: The max--three
hours.
Then --if you were going
conservatory--it's because you
got so many other demands on
your time.
Are you playing any solos
around here this year?
I should have asked that
question.
Kensho: Not so much--.
Prof: That's--
Kensho: --recital second
semester but--
Prof: All right.
We'll keep our eye out for
that.
All right.
So that's the theme and then
on--in variation two,
the piano will play the
>
downbeat, and the violin plays
off the beat.
I think for reasons of time,
we won't do that one though,
Kensho.
Let's go to the number three
where we get a good example of
staccato in the music--sort of
short, pointed notes.
>
Okay. So we'll stop there.
So when you hear Kensho playing
staccato then you know that we
are in variation three.
Variation four,
we've got--he's playing
sixteenth notes,
so it's going to go fairly fast
here,
I guess--or maybe not--but he's
got a lot to do here in
variation four.
>
Okay.
So he's really--this is going
to be a workout for me.
I hope I can keep up with this
lad today.
All right.
Then, yes, the one that sort of
scares me is variation five,
because then he plays the theme
and I have all of this fast
stuff underneath.
Let's just do a little bit of
that.
>
Okay.
So that's how that--has a
lovely, lovely theme there.
Now number six is sort of fun
because the interest here is in
the bass of the piano.
It's a good example of
something we'll be talking a lot
about in our course:
walking bass.
So the notes are all for the
most part contiguous and they
all come in the same note
value--in this case the eighth
note.
So the--here is the beat and
the-- <<plays
piano>>
and then he plays the melody
against that.
In number seven,
we have the violin playing
arpeggios.
We've talked about that.
So here are some arpeggios in
the violin.
>
Okay.
That'll give you a sense of
that.
Number eight is a tricky one
for us, the--keeping it
together--because of the triplet
pattern.
So let's do a little bit with
that.
>
And then nine we have sort of
an interlude.
It's like a transition.
Ten we're not going to do
anything with right now.
The violin plays harmony while
there's a kind of fast pattern
underneath.
Eleven there's a lot of--oh,
eleven is sort of my favorite
but it's a tricky one because of
the syncopation between the two
instruments.
>
So that's kind of a fun one.
And let's see.
We need to tell them also--I
like--
Maybe number thirteen is really
my favorite 'cause I got a very
simple theme to play and he has
to work like crazy.
And toward the end of that he's
playing triple stops.
It's not that the violin just
plays one line.
The violin can play two notes
at the same time,
it can play three notes at the
same time,
and if you really rip across
and shift quickly or just move
your bow quickly across the
strings you can give the
impression of four pitches,
but they-- all four have to be
in tune so you got to have four
fingers usually in four
different spots and that's hard
to do.
Do you want to play a quadruple
stop for them there just
to--anywhere,
or--
Kensho: Yeah.
>
Prof: So when you hear
those chords,
a violin playing chords,
well, that's easy--on the piano
>
or whatever it is <<plays
piano>>
--that's easy on the piano.
That's hard on these string
instruments 'cause you've got to
get four different fingers in
four different spots there.
Each of those notes has to be
adjusted just--fractionally just
right for it to stay in tune.
When he does it,
you think it's very simple,
right, easy to do.
It takes years to be able to do
that.
Questions before we launch in
to this?
Any questions?
So we're going to do the whole
thing for you.
Now be patient.
We're going to run over just a
little bit today but,
believe me, the--particularly
the end--you'll like it.
So, Kensho Watanabe playing
theme and variations on
Corelli's tune and bass "La
Folia."
>
Sorry.
We had the wrong page up here
and I was filling.
Sorry.
Okay. I think we need--okay.
Now we are back to it.
It must be--I had the wrong
page.
I'm sorry.
>
Sorry.
We still don't have--I'm very
sorry.
We found it. Okay.
We have--just have all these
pages and they go awry
sometimes.
Sorry.
Okay.
>
Bravo.
Thanks so much Kensho,
it's a great treat for me just
to be able to play with the guy.
I mean, what a luxury.
Thank you so much,
thank you so much.
Beautiful, beautiful music.